the tie no don't coming now with over 40
dishes to choose from feelings menu is
global both in size and choice
why is that this is Sansa sells
everything from all day English
breakfast
hoisin noodles to mexican platters this
is definitely more confusion and fusion
some of its even served in a bread bin
people don't eat out that surely are you
taking the piss
well we give it a bit of a polish 70% of
Philips food is brought in ready
prepared what happened to that the
Frenchman even gets his baguettes
delivered frozen and buying in
ready-made food which is an expensive
false economy what's the most popular
dish today the hamburgers and the crash
are they her maid er yeah yes they are
finally thank you very much Philippe
two sous chefs Munya an Altima are young
and inexperienced they clearly know
nothing beyond Phil's warped culinary
world and what's out there splash on the
sauce uncle Uncle Ben's you no way do
you want to be a head chef
three years [ __ ] me but move your ass
table here ready moon yeah well you want
to be a head chef well maybe in about 10
years time 10 years time yeah probably
have my own place I think that's what
I'd like they may be hungry for success
but if they think this is cooking
they're in for a surprise pretty lumpy
that isn't it now look like [ __ ]
porridge the bells the bells can you
tell me if this is starter and this main
tool so is it all together
yeah please because I can't guess you
need not take a nice one don't whine oh
yes here was the Greek salad
lunchtime service should be a quick
turnaround but with all the cock-ups
that customers are lucky to get their
food within 45 minutes and it's not
helped by the full-scale war raging
between restaurant manners of Dave and
Philip what is it between you and Dave
does your Hades are the right fit in
archaea and when the food does
eventually make it out to the customers
it comes boomeranging back just as fast
what's up
which one
it's my mistake obviously I should have
spotted it before it went out and it's
not just the undercooked fish that slips
through Philippe's net which what's
going on here so the plates are full up
coming back the rail going out it's not
one okay it's a ship stodgy and [ __ ]
disgusting
how many's cooked their burgers can be
barbecued grilled or fried but the
secret to success is to cook them to
order look at thin they are
we don't talk burgers now then I'm in an
order with recruiting them either for
tonight or even for tomorrow because the
thing here is for tomorrow the thing is
the oven is very very slow and we can't
put it any higher than that
have you lost applause no have you gone
a little bit [ __ ] bozo no that's how
you gonna come back again tomorrow it
will be reheated in the microwave
holy mackerel I'm a torturous treatment
of innocent food doesn't stop there you
deep fry the bacon now
we do agree buy this in France
well you'd be fairly shocked hey could
hang you upside down from the algae on
four you're full of genera we're in the
ship but if we want to turn the business
around yes I have to agree
we are in the [ __ ] [ __ ]